this is completely amazing to be here
thank you guys so much I I live in New
York now but I am originally from Canada
so I thought I was pretty funny over the
last little while right a lot of
Americans talking about moving to Canada
a lot of Americans mad about what's
happening here and they're like I'm just
gonna move to Canada as if you can just
do that
Canada is a real country with laws you
know but I like that there's a lot of
Americans that think Canada is just your
couch to go crash on
oh it's rough here let me go to the
cottage up north I grew up in Canada and
I grew up without any real money and I
used to think that really sucked you
know I had the clothes that didn't fit
and my mom would just buy buy cookies
that just sent cookies on the box and I
take them to school and kids you like
you know who makes those cookies I like
cookies cookies makes cookies you know I
now know one great thing about growing
up poor and that is that poor people do
not have ridiculous allergies to things
I grew up with a lot of poor people I've
never heard something go oh my god what
is that bread you know I'm allergic
people born with money are allergic to
everything
fabrics vegetables grown at night poor
people just everything I met a guy who
told me he was allergic to fruit that
has skin on it that's a rich kid guys
and fruit that has skin I think you
meant to say fruit just say fruit and be
done with it don't make you a problem
bigger than it is I can't eat chips have
coming to bag that's chips that's all of
the chips just say I could have Pringles
and keep walking I just never heard
those types of allergies and for people
you know poor people it's more like
where's my dad's other things like that
I know people get sad about I actually
grow up myself without a dad and people
do get sad like you don't have a dad how
did you learn to shave your little no
dad face how to walk in your little no
dad legs it's not that big a deal
do any people have not had dads and done
something go with their lives pretty big
last we got Barack Obama no dad Jack
Nicholson jay-z a lot of the NBA it's a
very successful group of millionaires
I don't think LeBrons ever coming down
the court said look know is that there's
a Maserati in the parking lot people get
real sad about somebody asked me wants
how I learned how to play catch they're
like without a dad who taught you how to
play catch like gravity it's not a hard
game to learn you keep your hand open
when something hits your head you just
close your hand not like me not having a
dad you throw something at me it just
hits me in the chest you're gonna throw
some keys like what's wrong with you man
you know I didn't have a dad shut them
down I'll go and get them
I grew up in apartments my whole life
not having a dad and it's made me
absolutely terrified of big houses I
don't know how anybody lives in a big
house in a big house there's way too
many places for murderers to be you know
if you're in an apartment you're like I
wonder if there's a murderer in this
apartment you just put your back against
the wall you look at the door the one
door that goes in and out of this place
you check lefty check right like hey no
murderers here and you're like oh and I
live on the 10th floor and if you live
on the 10th floor of a building and
somebody scales that building to murder
you you earned that murder all right you
did something so bad that somebody was
like 7 gotta keep going hey there I'm
just assuming people in big houses when
they go to bed or like wow I guess I'll
go downstairs and uh check the basement
and all that you know make sure there's
nobody down there um check all these
linen closets that are around so I like
talking to people they're like I don't
want to live in the city dangerous I'm
gonna go live in the country where it's
safe like all right you want to live in
the country around nobody in the middle
of nothing which is the set of every
horror movie ever made there's not a lot
of horror movies that take place in
apartments you know he would just be
jason standing in the lobby
buzzing the bells trying to get upstairs
[Applause]
you